This video is made possible by audible.
Use My link audible.com forward slash
biographics or tax to biographics.
Do 500 500 in the U,
s only to get a free book,
plus you get to audible originals
and a 30 day free trial,
so for free.
Just click the link in the description
below is the Roku Yamamoto.
Was the mastermind behind the worst
attack on American soil ever that doesn't
attack on Pearl Harbor.
Brought war with Japan Bidding Yamamoto
against the best military minds of the
US armed forces.
In the end though,
it took a clandestine mid and fascination
to bring them to heel and this week's
bind graphics.
We examined the life of
a sea rocket Yamamoto.
Yeah.
Well No.
Tony was born as the
Roku on April the fourth,
18,
84 in the town of Naga Erica
on the island of Honshu.
His father tack our new study.
Yoshi had been involved in an unsuccessful
Samurai lead rebellion against the
imperial governments back in 1877.
The government subsequent crackdown on
the Samurai made it difficult for to Kano
to find work and he was forced to move
all over 100 trying to secure a job.
I've.
You're returning to Naga.
Okay.
His wife died and soon after he married
his younger sister in law together,
they had three children.
The youngest of these was this rocky.
The name means 56,
which was his father's age
when he was born to Kona.
It was an educated man who,
when he could find a position
worked as a school teacher.
He passed his appreciation for
knowledge onto his children.
The most gifted of who you see,
rocky.
The boys saw education as the route
to breaking the cycle of poverty.
That was his lot in life
in 19.
Oh,
one is Iraq is diligence and application
to his studies paid off when he wanted
an appointment to the
imperial Navy Academy.
In fact,
his application test score was the second
highest in the entire country for the
next three years,
between the ages of 16 and 19,
he lived at the Naval Academy.
You had to at a dream
a city near Hiroshima.
In the southern part of Japan,
life of the academy was spotting.
Discipline is a rocky,
were acquitted himself competently,
but it was during the fourth
year of the cadetship,
which we spent at sea that he read it
again to shine is enabled as quickly
recognized leadership qualities in the
man just by only standing at five foot
three inches and weighing
around 120 pounds.
He was physically skills being adapted
to both gymnastics and the martial arts.
Kendo,
unlike most other students,
he was not interested in
drinking and socializing,
but would rather spend his time at reading
the Bible and getting a head on his
studies.
In November of 1994 this year,
rocky graduated from the Naval Academy.
Seventh out of 200 since
February of that year,
Japan had been at war with Russia,
runs.
See Rocky was immediately
thrown right into the fray.
It was assigned to the warship
Nisshin on the night of May,
the 26th,
19.
Oh,
five.
The climactic battle of the war began
with the Russian Baltic fleet attacking
the Japanese fleet and
the Tricia Shima straight.
The mission was one of eight imperial
ships presence out of 89 social ships with
more modern ships,
greater speeds,
and better trained crews that Japanese
emerged victorious with 21 Russian ships
being sunk and seven being captured.
It was the victory that the Japanese
had been desperately needing and it
propelled them to final victory.
However,
versie rocky,
the price for the jury,
it was DB,
one of the gun barrels on board his
ship and burst with the shrapnel flying
everywhere he calls up launch
piece of metal in the thigh,
and dozens of smaller fragments peppered
all throughout his lower body in
addition to have his fingers
well hanging by a threat,
he was evacuated to a hospital and did
not return to duty until August the
fifth.
Still,
he was recognized for his bravery in
this fast test undefined with a letter of
citation and personal commendation
from Admiral [inaudible] Togo.
After recovering from his injuries,
this Iraq,
he served on three ships on one of them.
He traveled to the west
coast of the United States,
giving him his first
American interaction in 19.
Oh,
eight agency rocky completed the basic
course at the naval gunnery school going
on to graduate from the
advanced course in 1911.
He then spent time on a battleship before
attending the Naval Staff College in
Nineteen Thirteen and see rocky excelled
in staff training being Mr x by his
Tutus as a man on the rise.
Following his graduation in 1916,
he was appointed to the second battle
squadron as a leftenant commander.
It was around this time
that Tacoma is Iraq,
became Yamamoto is rocky with both his
parents having died in 1912 and having
older brothers,
it was clear that this Iraqi would
never come to head the Chicano plan.
Yeah,
so the Yamamoto cannon was
in need of a new mail APP.
The clams saw the rising young
naval officer as the perfect fit.
This is what I'm saying,
a man into a family in
order to serve as the male.
There was quite a common practice
and it was accepted by us,
the rocky,
however it required that he find a wife
and two sons do continue the Yamamoto
name.
It was at the age of 34.
Then in 1918,
the TC Roku entered into an arranged
marriage the few months later in 1919,
he was assigned to the United States
do take up an assignment as a naval
representative.
He spends a month at Harvard University
studying the English language event,
continued to study independently to
master English while also learning all he
could about the oil industry,
which was vital to the operation of an
efficient navy while in the USC also
picks up a penchant for gambling which
he proved to be quite successful.
In fact,
he took a tour of Mexican oil fields which
was partly financed from his gambling
proceeds in 1921 and see rocky returned
to Japan where he received a posting,
an instructor at the Naval Staff College.
Over the five years of his service.
In this capacity,
he deepened his knowledge of oil while
also developing a fascination with
aviation.
In 1926,
he was assigned to the United States for
a second time where he stayed for two
years as he rocky's two great passions
combined in 1928 when he was given
command of the Imperial Navy's
first aircraft carrier ecology.
He retains this post for
a little over a year.
Within that time,
he developed a strong bonds with
the men under his command z grit.
The tomorrow they're strict,
but Faq Monda.
Let's see.
Rocky was mastery of the English language,
made him a valuable asset to
the Japanese high command,
and in October of 1929,
he was stationed to London to act as an
assistant to the Japanese delegation to
the London Naval
Conference of Nineteen 30.
During his time in London,
he received the news that he had been
promoted to rear admiral back in Japan.
Yamamoto was given yet another
role within the imperial navy.
He became head of the technical
division of the aeronautics department.
After three years,
he then found himself back
in command to the economy.
He threw himself into this role,
disciplining and training as
aviators with absolute precision.
However,
eight months into this role,
he was again selected
for service overseas.
The preliminary discussions for the second
London naval conference took place in
London in October of 1934 and the gamma
motor was selected as a chief delegate.
He was tasked with pressing Japan's claim
for a better naval construction ratio,
which had previously been set at 60
percent of the battleship and carrier
strength of the United States and Britain.
Despite his own personal misgivings,
he proved to be the right man for the job.
His opposition negotiators from Britain
and the US were impressed with his
intelligence and his reasonableness.
He put the demands from his government
on the table which worth and naval parity
with the other two powers.
This was never going to be acceptable
to the Brits and the Americans and
Yamamoto.
He knew this,
the negotiations.
They went nowhere and the conference
broke up without resolution even though we
had not been able to achieve
as government's ambitions.
Yamamotos prominence at the conference
had made in internationally famous.
When he returned to Japan,
he faced a period of stagnation
which was very troubling to him.
In fact,
he seriously considered at this point,
resigning from the navy.
Fun Kit was resolved though in December
of 1935 when he was appointed chief of
the aeronautics department
at the Navy Ministry.
He was now the boss of everything
to do with naval aviation in Japan.
This gave him the ability to put into
development some of the concepts that he
had previously worked on.
These included the type 96
land based attack plane.
This one's the most advanced attack plane
possessed by any navy in the world and
would form a central part of Yamamotos
offensive plans against the United
States.
Now,
on February the 26th,
19,
36,
there was an attempted
military coup in Japan.
The nationalistic governments
placed Admiral Magonia Sama.
Whereas the new minister of the Navy
Yamamoto excepted the position of vice
navy,
Minnesota.
He sat about reinstilling,
a lost discipline and the navy's command
dismissing those who didn't meet the
standards.
He also actively worked to prevent
the army's push towards war.
Nineteen 37 was to prove to be a key,
uh,
in the advancement of Japan's war stance
in the wake of starting a war on her
doorstep with China.
She signed a tripartite pact with
Germany and definitely yellow.
Jay was against the pact and he
wasn't shy about voicing his opinion.
This brought him into increasing
conflicts with the army administration and
their right wing followers.
He received numerous death threats.
These didn't phase him and he appears
to have accepted that sooner or later he
would simply be assassinated.
A crisis occurred in 1939.
This was when the Germans signs
a nonaggression pact with Russia,
the traditional enemies of the Japanese.
On August the 23rd,
the entire Japanese cabinet resigned,
resulting in Yamamotos loss
of his position as vice
navy minister along with his
Superior Navy Minister
Uni before leaving office.
However,
you know I had appointed Yamamoto as
the commander in chief of the combined
imperial fleet.
Yamamoto was a highly
experienced commander and to
get the respect of his men,
he was seen as a pacifist at a time when
the country was marching towards war.
However,
he threw himself into the
position with his usual Gusto,
pushing aside his own reservations and
stepping up training and preparation for
the coming conflict.
By the end of 1940,
the pro German factions within the armed
forces were driving the country towards
a conflict with the United States,
though personally opposed
to taking on the use.
I'm the moto began planning
for succession eventuality.
He was adamant that the only chance for
success against America laying with a
massive surprise attack that
would take out the American fleet,
followed up by the blitzkrieg like tactics
that the Germans were using with such
positive effects in Europe.
It repeatedly stated that if a wall was
to be one against the United States,
it had to be completed within six months.
Otherwise,
the economic and manpower advantage of
the Americans would inevitably prevailed.
In July 19,
41,
the United States responded to continue
Japanese aggression in China by imposing
a trade embargo on Japan and freezing
all Japanese assets in its country,
Britain and the Netherlands.
They quickly followed suit.
The most crippling effect
was the loss of oil imports,
which accounted for 90 percent of Japan's
usage and of course the largest user
of oil and the country
was Japan's imperial navy.
The Japanese response was to further
step up preparation for war while also
looking to seize control of the oil
reserves held in the Dutch east indies and
the British had in the Far East.
Yamamoto believed that any attack on
or British possessions withdraw the
Americans into an armed conflict.
It was at this time that
Yamamoto formulated the plan
for a decisive preemptive
strike on the American naval
base at Pearl Harbor in Hawaii.
He believed that such a crushing blow
would destroy American morale and lead to
a negotiated peace settlement.
The plan was risky and many
officials were opposed to it.
It's big volumes about Yamamoto is
prestige and influence that he was able to
push the plan through to a final approval.
The plan was actually rejected by
the navy general staff several times,
but finally I'm a moto.
Had to put his foot down as long
as he was commander in chief.
He called his command is
the Pearl Harbor attack.
We'd go ahead.
He then went to the naval general staff
and told them that unless the plan was
approved,
he and his entire staff would resign.
The idea of going to war with out Yamamoto
was a scary prospect to the navy bras
and they finally relented.
Yamamoto is planned for Pearl Harbor,
was to sink as many
battleships as possible.
He sold the battleship as the symbol of
American naval superiority and figured
that the sudden loss of the majority of
that reserve would destroy the American
fighting spirit.
However,
staff officer for the first athletes,
[inaudible] Granada,
I felt that it was more advantageous do
concentrate on singing American aircraft
carriers.
In the end,
a compromise was reached.
The first wave of the attack comprising
of 40 torpedo planes would be directed
at two carriers.
The other 24 planes would
focus on the eight battleships.
That could also potentially be that
another 50 level Bowman's web to head for
battleship row where most of that
or ships were expected to be buffed.
Meanwhile,
54 dive bombers were the
escorting fighters were to
attack the oil fields on a
Awahoo who the second wave of the attack
was to comprise 81 dive bombers and was
intended to finish off the cruisers with
their bombs being too small to damage
the battleships.
As it turned down to the attack
during the early hours of December,
the seventh,
19,
41 was far more successful and
it's targeting of battleships,
cruises,
none of which were actually
in the doc that day.
The battleships so in West Virginia was
sunk while the California was struck
with two torpedoes eventually sinking
and the Nevada with a single strike that
also brought her down.
All of this was achieved in only
11 minutes in battleship row.
The Arizona was struck with a
1,760 pounds armor piercing,
bombed the forward magazine of the ship,
exploded,
killing 1000,
177 offices and creaming the
attack was a complete success.
Achieving Yamamotos objective
of decimating American
naval power in one fell
sweep.
18 ships had been sunk or damaged while
only 29 Japanese aircraft had been shot
down.
Most pleasing dmr motor was that five
battleships that either sunk or beached in
the bigger picture of things.
However,
the attack at Pearl Harbor it achieved
little yamamoto is emphasis on destroying
battleships.
It was not a sound policy.
The Americans were already moving towards
carriers rather than battleships and
the Pearl Harbor attack merely sped up.
This transition further more than
rather than breaking American morale is
Yamamoto had thought that the attack
served as a rallying cry to drive the
American zone.
Two final victory
with the United States Declaration of
war against Japan on December the eighth,
19,
41.
The Japanese had to devise a strategy
to overcome this far greater power.
It was decided to fight a
defensive campaign where
the Americans would be drawn
into the Pacific eastern,
worn down to the point of accepting
a negotiated peace settlement.
Meanwhile,
the Japanese would occupy key territories
in the Asia Pacific moving down into
Australasia or in the central Pacific,
Yemen military believe that
when Singapore was taken,
the time would be right to sue for peace
with the success of his brainchild,
the Pearl Harbor Attack
Yamamotos influence group.
He was instrumental in planning invasions
on Malaysia and the Philippines as
well as Guam in Singapore.
In early February of 1942,
he moved his staff headquarters onto the
super battleship yamato with Singapore
having fallen.
Yamamoto believed that it was time for
his government to pressure the allies for
peace.
It's lack of action on this greatly
frustrated him despite his conviction that
our campaign that went for more
than six months would be disastrous.
He was forced to plan out
the next phase of the war.
However,
his ideas were at odds with the naval
general staff who wanted to concentrate on
Australia where he was intent on taking
control of the Indian subcontinent.
The army,
however,
refused to back such a plan and it
was quickly taken off the table.
The first major setback for the Japanese,
the code with the battle of coral sea
between may the fourth and the eighth,
1942,
which successfully hold to the
Japanese invasion of New Guinea.
Yeah,
million.
So we continue to butt heads with the
naval general stuff as he now proposed an
attack on Midway atoll that would draw
out the remnants of the American fleet
from Hawaii.
Wires could be utterly destroyed.
Resistance was stiff with general staff
members pointing out the midway was too
close to Pearl Harbor and
too far away from Japan.
You have a motorcycle now used his old
tactic of threatening to resign and you
go his way again.
The attack on midway required Yamamoto,
two coordinators,
fleets over huge stretches of water.
Yeah,
Moto,
but board.
The Yamato personally led
one battle group and self.
What he didn't know was that the Americans
had broken their secret codes and
we're already aware of the
attack and advance through us.
Carriers were sent to midway in
order to surprise the Japanese.
In the ensuing battle,
four Japanese carriers were sent to
the bottom of the ocean acknowledging
defeat.
Yamamoto ordered his remaining ships
back to base the defeat at midway,
was a humiliation for Yamamoto and see
received much criticism for us still,
he was able to retain his
position as commander chief,
largely because to remove in would have
been too demoralizing for the men under
his command.
Over the next few months,
the Japanese achieved limited success
against the fleet around Guata canal in
the Solomon Islands.
The Battle of Guadalcanal,
however,
was another crushing
defeat for the Japanese
in the wake of Guadalcanal.
Yamamoto set out on a morale boosting
tour of af four spaces across the South
Pacific on April the 14th,
1943 and message which announced his
exact itinerary on route to a base in the
Solomon Islands was
intercepted by US intelligence.
This presented the Americans
with the perfect opportunity,
do assassinate the Japanese
naval commander in chief.
It was a risk and that it would portray
the Americans' ability to break Japanese
code,
but Yamamoto was seen as such a big
fish that it was deemed worth giving up.
This intelligence,
a plan,
nicknames operation.
Vengeance was put into operation with
the objective of killing Yamamoto.
18 US fighter pilots were chosen from
the base at Guadalcanal to participate in
the operation.
14 of them would provide cover at around
20,000 feet while for others for them
to a strikeforce to blow yamamotos
plane right out of the sky.
The attack it was set for April the 18th
that morning that was not one but two
m,
one type one betty bombers
along with six a six,
seven,
zero five just to provide
escort and yamamotos fleet.
It wasn't long into the flight when
the four American p 38 swept seen
approaching the bomber that was carrying
Emma Moto immediately began to descend
while the escort planes
moved into intercept,
the Americans bombed so they weren't
able to prevent the [inaudible] from
achieving their objectives.
With both of the betty
bombers receiving strikes,
both of the planes crashed.
However,
an autopsy on his body revealed that
Yamamoto who was sitting on the starboard
side of the plane behind
the plane commander had been
struck by bullets to the
drawer and shoulder and was probably
dead before the plane hit the grounds.
Yamamotos body was found later that day.
It had been thrown from the wreckage,
still strapped to the seat.
The death of Yamamoto was not revealed
to the Japanese people until may the 20,
fast more than a month
after he was shot down,
more than a million people lined the
streets of Tokyo as his ashes passed by.
So today's video was
made possible by audible,
who I'm sure many of
you know about already.
I've been a longtime customer of audible
reading tons of books on all sorts of
subjects.
In fact,
it's kind of a funny story.
I personally really love autobiographies
and biographies and listening to those
three audible.
I was actually inspired
me to stop this channel.
No kidding.
It all kind of came full circle,
so thanks for that order bulk.
There are loads of autobiographies on
audible and I bet that if it's a notable
book,
there's going to be a cool
audiobook version of it as well.
Also related to this video,
there are tons of audio
books on World War Two,
the Pacific theater,
Pearl Harbor itself.
Lots and lots of those.
I just did a quick search and the entire
first page of results are all super
highly rated books about this
attack and its consequences.
Now,
what about was always a good deal and
you'd go into an audio book a month for a
low fee,
but now there's even more.
In addition them is get
to audible originals every
single month in addition to
their book of choice.
These are from some of the world's
most celebrated storytellers,
journalists,
novelists,
and many others.
There's plenty to choose from.
There's also fitness and
health workouts for members,
so horrible was always great,
but now there's even more
if you've been putting off,
signing up for it to do so.
No longer go search Pearl Harbor in
order bowl and grab something that takes
your fancy.
There's loads of great reviewed books,
like I say,
just go to audible.com
forward slash biographics.
This also a link in the description below.
Doing that also helps support this
show and helps us keep more biographics
videos coming your way.
Again,
get started with a free book now with
a 30 day free trial@audible.com forward
slash biographics,
or if you're in America
tax to biographics do 500,
500.
So I really hope you found
this video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos twice a week.
So hit that subscribe button,
hit that bell button.
If you really want to get notifications,
and as always,
thank you for watching.